hello everyone and welcome to a
spectacular game from round six of the
United States Championship between Ray
Robson and Fabiana Caruana
now you might remember the one video I
made about Ray Robson and his famous the
Tales from the Crypt game if you haven't
seen that I seriously do recommend it
it's one of the coolest games you'll
ever see I will put a link to it in the
description below it's the first thing
you'll see in the description so be sure
to check it out as its it's a really
cool game but this is around 6 and he
faces Fabiana Cora wanna with the black
pieces and he's not afraid to play e4
against him so once again corona goes
for his well we can say famous petrov
defense and it's very interesting what
do you think cousins best bet for
november is is it to prepare again at
the play against the petrol or to simply
avoid efore and what do you think
carlson will do will he avoid efore
altogether or will he will he try to out
prepare Caruana in the petrov but that
being said let's see the game so we have
a four by Robson and we have E 5 and in
that video Tales from the Crypt I did
say a couple of words about the Ray
Robson and his chest career so far so
that's why I also recommend you to check
it out
Knight to f3 and the Knight to f6 so we
have the better of defense Knight to e5
capturing the pawn d6 Knight to f3 and
the Knight captures on e4 this is the
classical variation and it's something
you if you play the petrol or against
the petrol you've probably seen a lot of
times Knight to c3 this is the names of
each variation Knight captures in c3d
captures on c3 and here we have Bishop
to e7 it's a very interesting move
because if you remember in Carmona's
game versus Carrick in here car wanna
play Knight to c6 and it's the game he
lost against Kerrigan
so it's probably a game Ray Robson knows
very well and he prepared you know in
regards to that game so Caruana changes
the move order a bit just to mix it up
Bishop to e7
we have Bishop to e3 now and castles by
Caruana Queen to d2 preparing queenside
castle Knight d7 and
we do have queenside castle c6 preparing
d5 King Tubby one and now comes d5c for
getting rid of the double spawn we have
a nice to be six captures on d5 Knight
captures on d5 and now Bishop to c4
so Robson is offering his Bishop on e3
in order in order to exchange more
pieces and here afar we said that he did
consider Bishop to e6 simply protecting
the night but he didn't think that black
actually had anything there and that if
white simply exchanged that it would be
okay for black and white as well so
instead he played Bishop to f5 this is a
pawn sacrifice which Robson accepts and
Fabi said that he did prepare this at
home although he didn't analyze the
position after the pawn sacrifice
thoroughly he just saw that the computer
evaluated the position as as okay for
black you know it's not like the black
is black is worse if he gives up a bond
here so he did play this but you can
even watch caranas interview about this
move and about the game I will put a
link in the description below it's it's
the entire video from the United States
Championship on st. Louis chess channel
and the entire video is about 6 hours
long but I will put in the description
also the time marks where the interview
starts so be sure to check that out as
well
Bishop captures on d5 accepting the pawn
sacrifice see characters and affair and
now Queen character son b5 and now Queen
to c8 so defending the bishop on f5 but
also threatening Bishop captures on c2
with check nights the d4 defending c2
and also attacking the bishop on f5
bishop moves and we have king to a-1 so
now the C pawn can move the it's no
longer pinned as the king is no longer
on b1 rook to e8 we have rook H 2 e 1
and now Bishop to f6 so you can see for
the price of one for a one point Fabi
has two excellent bishops so he does
have the bishop pair and they're eyeing
that king side very meanly he has a very
nice place rockin e8 the queen is
excellent on c8 and he does have an
undeveloped rook but you know you can
have everything
we have c3 rook to e5 now bringing the
rook into the attack using the Queen
Queen to b3 and the now a6 now we have
Bishop to f4
rook captures any one rook captures any
one and Queen to d7 Bishop to e5 as the
knight on d4 was attacked twice we have
looked to it pinning the bishop on e5
and now f4 and Bishop to d8 not allowing
any captures but okay no captures are
yet possible because the rook on et1 is
still hanging a four robson makes some
room for Ace King on a2 and h6 fabi does
the same
we have rook to d1 now on pinning and
Queen to g4 as the Queen was on D file
so pressuring the rook on d1 and but
also attacking the pawn on g2 rook to d2
now defending the pawn and we have b5
now an excellent move that opens up
opens up the a file a capture some b5 a
capture some b5 and this is the moment
where rail Robson probably got scared of
actually of actually playing for
advantage against the World Chess
Championship Challenger but it's not
it's not all that easy I mean you you
have to calculate you're probably in
time trouble the move he should have
played here is Queen captures on b5 and
there are no there isn't any immediate
danger of this Bishop moving anywhere
because it can't really move anywhere
with tempo I mean if this Bishop wasn't
here you would have this rook to e8
check and since the bishop is slicing
all the way here this would be game over
but there is no way to move this bishop
good tempo and after the Queen captures
an b5 the Queen is also attacking the
rook on e8 so you do have to react to
this so probably after f6 attacking the
bishop but also defending the rock on e8
bishop has to move Bishop to d6 and this
Bishop to d6 is probably the move Robson
missed when considering Queen captures
on b5 because now even if this Bishop
moves you you always have this retreat
with Bishop to a three for example
Bishop to e7 now threatening rook e8 but
you simply play rookie two and now after
okay check Bishop to a3 and now the
problem is
after Bishop characters on a3 you have
Queen to d5 check so maybe even if he
saw that Bishop to d6 area maybe he
missed Queen d5 check now after King
moves to simply capture and now white is
winning but okay he didn't go for Queen
captures on b5 he played Queen to d1 off
the trade of Queens
but now Fabi goes back Queen d7 and now
Fabi does have time to reorganize his
forces f5 and we have an excellent
excellent position to really consider a
lot of moves here what do you play here
your Bishop is under attack you don't
want to play a move like like this
simply g4 will trap your Bishop if you
go back you're you're you're not really
doing anything you're giving white the
next move and there are a lot of things
to consider for example if you capture
the bishop on e5 for example your
thought process might be I capture
Bishop on e5 he captures a mine mine and
g6 and all as well well not really if
rook captures pawn captures now you
don't have the option of capturing back
on g6 if you capture you get Knight to
f3 now your rook is attacked and also
your queen is attacked on d7 and after
Queen a7 chip king b1 now your rook is
still attacked on me v and the bishop is
attacked on d8 and there is no move that
prevents both of these threats so after
let's say Bishop g5 you simply captured
the rope go shop capture screen captures
and at the end of this little skirmish
black is down a piece and of course
losing the game so after f55 we found
the the best move that there is on the
board he played Bishop to g5 and now
it's it's apparent that because this
bishop is under attack on e5 that such a
move is possible now if you play for
example a pawn captures on g6 you get
Bishop captures on undie to and after
Queen captures you get rook captures on
e5 and after G capture screen captures
black is up the exchange and most likely
winning this game
so after Bishop to g5 Robson played rook
to b3 and now comes the Bishop captures
on f5 a rock - a check was also possible
but after King b1 you would play Bishop
captures on a5 all the same so Knight
captures Queen captures and we have
Bishop to g3 this is this is the move
that most likely cost Robson the game
now you you have to play a sari instead
of this Bishop to g3 you have to go
Bishop to d6 because you really need
this Bishop 283 retreat but he played
Bishop to g3 and now comes Luke 2:8
check King to be won and now rook back
to d8 and there is a double attack on
this rook the rook is pinned from the
Queen your only move is king - see - and
now I really want you to pause it pause
the position here and try to find the
winning idea for for fabi okay some of
you asked me in the comments if I could
maybe say if you're supposed to find
checkmate when a piece or something well
no in this position you're just supposed
to continue the attack it's the only
move that allows black to efficiently
continue continue the attack so feel
free to posit that we'll give it a
couple of seconds as usual for those of
you who found the move congratulations
you are an excellent attacker and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
the move far we played was before before
now you can see that the immediate idea
is b3 you either force the King to
capture and move back and then you win
the whole rook so you do have to react
to this C capture son before it was
played in the game but it doesn't help
if you play something like b3 with ideas
of not opening up the C file because now
comes rook to e8 with which plans of
rushing down the second-ranked and after
King prevents this now C captures be
kept frozen c3 rook captures and now
look back to the 8th and there is no
defense against troop to d2 Queen has to
move and then rook to D to check comes
Rock blocks and then Bishop to f6 check
King to c1 and now simply move the rook
and prepare Queen to f1 and this will be
checkmate after better blocks and Queen
captures so you can prevent this for a
couple of most for example rook f2 now
comes Queen f5 threatening Queen to e1
then B 4 and then Queen to a3 check and
it's all over you have to block this now
comes Queen III check rogue d2 and Queen
captures this is checkmate there are a
lot of other checkmate patterns but this
the the most forcing one a flag defense
correctly so after before Robson played
seek after some before we have rook to
see a check King Tubby three and now
Queen to e6 check a rock to d5 blocking
if you try running away with the King
for example King to a four-year getting
checkmate a true Cade check King b5
Queen a6 check King c5 now comes rook c8
check came to d4 Roxy for check King e5
and Queen to e6 this was all forced and
this is checkmate
so after Queen to e6 check Robson tried
to block rock to d5 here we have rook to
DA pinning King to c4 and now comes
Queen to c6 check and it was in this
position that Robson resigned the game
there's a really no move you can make to
prevent that will prevent you from
losing this rook and if you try rock to
c5 with ideas that if black captures
your queen you will capture the black
queen then simply Queenie for check and
after the King moves you will grab the
Queen and it's winning and game and
fortunately Fabi did play this h6 move
so there is no magnet any bank back rank
ideas here for white so yeah after rook
c5 no after Queen to c6 check rail
Robson resigned the game and a very nice
victory for Fabiano Caruana and yeah I
did prepare the final standings I just I
don't remember if I prepared them let me
just check sorry about that sorry that's
me at all
no let me just check a couple of more
layers yeah I did prepare them here
there so these are the standings after
round 6 so as you can see the winner I
mean currently the leader is Samuel
Shanklin with four and a half out of six
points Fabiano which this win against
rail Robson is now in second place with
four out of six points then we have West
this also would 4 out of 6 and then
Vajrasana Kobe and Hikaru Nakamura
Yaroslav durable Geoffrey Ching
Vida Soria a wonderland Alexandre
Lenderman Alexander oh nice truck and
rail Robson in last place after losing
this game to Fabiano so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and I really recommend you check out
that very nice game by Ray Robson Tales
from the Crypt in the link in the
description below I would also like to
thank young Michael Enka William Avery
and John SAR for a contribution to my
channel think a lot I really appreciate
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting video
thank you